[Musique]
c'est un grand pape qui disparaît avec
Jean XXII en 1958 la fumée blanche du
conclave annonça au monde l'élection du
cardinal rankalli au trône de
Saint-Pierre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on avait parlé d'un pape de transition
mais l'effet devait bientôt démentir
cette idée cet homme de 77 ans qui pour
la première fois bénissait la foule du
balcon de Saint-Pierre devait se montrer
l'un des esprits les plus Hardy qui est
jamais présidé au destinée de l'église
[Musique]
hardi dans les gestes de la vie il
renoua à la prison de Regina Chelli avec
la très ancienne tradition de la visite
aux prisonniers on le vit au milieu de
1300 condamnés leur apporter espoir et
consolation
on le vit ouvrir au Vatican ces
appartements particuliers au cinéma et
se prêtait avec une extrême bonne amie
aux exigences de la technique détails
mineurs mais qui marque un homme
celui-là était un homme simple mais en
même temps un esprit audacieux
il reçu la plupart des chefs d'État le
général de Gaulle en 1959 s'entretint
longuement avec lui mais l'acte le plus
lourd de conséquences de son règne aura
été avec la réunion du concile
écumenique de donner à l'église une
impulsion nouvelle c'est cet homme c'est
ce pape qui disparaît aujourd'hui et le
monde entier s'incline devant ce grand
mort
[Musique]
et voici les images de cette fin
universellement regrettée au soir de ce
lundi de Pentecôte la foule romaine se
précède sur la place Saint-Pierre devant
la masse du palais de sixtain ou dans
ses appartements du dernier étage le
papagonisait depuis bientôt 92
sur le parvis la foule suivait la messe
en plein air mais personne n'ignorait
plus que la médecine s'était déclarée
impuissante devant le mal et que la
dernière heure était proche
dans la nuit qui tombait la fenêtre de
la chambre du pape s'éclaira il était
19h49 Jean 23 s'était éteint donnant sa
vie comme il l'avait dit pour l'église
pour le concile et pour la paix
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la visite des souverains suédois à Paris
s'est brillamment achevé sur une soirée
de gala à l'Opéra le roi Gustave VI ça
donne fait la reine Louise haute du
président de Gaulle et souverain d'un
royaume qui n'a pas connu la guerre
depuis un siècle et demi renoue avec la
France des liens très anciens puisqu'ils
ont pour ancêtre direct le français
Bernadotte qui fut maréchal de Napoléon
1er c'est pourquoi à Pau les illustres
visiteurs ont rendu visite à la famille
toujours fixée au pays de leur insecte
madame Marie-Louise artigualas de Berry
dépourvu une petite cousine et Monsieur
Charles Bernadotte aujourd'hui gardien
du musée Béarnais et hier employé le
chemin de fer un cousin
[Musique]
nous deux étaient bien entendu au
premier rang de l'assistance qui
accueillait le roi Gustave et la reine
Louise et aux places d'honneur au
déjeuner faire au souverain
[Musique]
il devait tous ensuite rendre visite à
la maison natale du fondateur de
l'actuel dynastie suédois
[Musique]
c'est entre ces murs dans ce décor
rustique que se passe à l'enfance de
celui qui devait s'illustrer sur les
champs de bataille de la Révolution et
de l'Empire et finir sur un trône le
grand ancêtre français d'une des
dernières dynasties royales de notre
temps
[Musique]
à l'Elysée le général de Gaulle a reçu
la visite des présidents des républics
africaines francophones après la
conférence au sommet d'Addis-Abeba les
chefs des jeunes États ont voulu avant
de regagner leur capital respective
conférés à Paris des résultats et des
perspectives de ses premières assises de
l'Afrique indépendante
[Musique]
pour plusieurs centaines de milliers de
Britanniques le Derby d'Epsom a été
l'occasion d'une garden party monstre
on aurait presque fini par oublier qu'on
était venu là pour assister au triomphe
de la race chevaline il est vrai
qu'avant même le départ de la course les
Anglais ne se faisaient pas d'illusions
ils étaient certains que le vainqueur de
la plus grande épreuve hippique de
l'année ne serait pas un de leurs
cheveux
français Realco était alors Dieu
imbattables et ils avaient raison
monté par Yves Saint Martin le petit
jockey miracle de l'écurie Dupré helkoz
est un musée comme un petit pou sur les
2400 mètres du derby terminant sa
promenade de santé avec six longueurs
d'avance
une promenade de grands Seigneur puisque
Realco a ramassé 50 millions sous ses
sabots dorés
Cadarache et désormais un nom important
d'enquipement nucléaire français sur
1400 hectares d'un seul bloc s'étendent
les installations du centre inaugurées
par Monsieur Gaston Palewski ministre
d'État ces Cadarache qui allaient de
piles qui seront les centrales
nucléaires de l'an 2000 produira le
plutonium nécessaire à l'industrie la
première de ces piles Pégase vient
d'entrer en service
[Musique]
Cadarache marque un nouveau pas dans
l'essor de l'industrie nucléaire en
France
[Musique]
incompréhensible accident en Allemagne
un hélicoptère de l'armée américaine
utilisée pour poser vos fêtes d'un
clocher neuf une croix de 400 kg à
soudain capoter sans raison apparente
alors que l'opération venait de se
terminer
rien explique pour l'instant la chute
verticale de l'appareil dont l'accident
dramatique a fait deux morts et un
blessé grave
[Musique]
Notre-Dame de Paris la cathédrale la
plus illustre de la chrétienté avec
Saint-Pierre de Rome a eu 800 ans cette
année sous ses voûtes vient de retentir
le TDM de Berlioz première des
manifestations qui marqueront ce 8e
centenaire
[Musique]
Notre-Dame c'est sans doute un de ces
émouvantes témoignages que nous a laissé
la fois du Moyen-Âge mais c'est aussi
800 ans de l'histoire de Paris et de
l'histoire de France
[Musique]
l'un des trois portails le portail de
Sainte-Anne évoque l'évêque Maurice de
Sully qui en 1163 décida de donner à
Paris une cathédrale digneudelle dès
lors Notre Dame devait participer à tous
les grands événements
sa construction n'était pas terminée
quand Saint-Louis y apporta la couronne
d'épines
[Musique]
au 14ème siècle enfin achevé elle
resplendissait de tout son éclat
Paris vaut bien d'une messe avait dit
Henri IV Notre-Dame fut donc le témoin
de sa réconciliation avec les Parisiens
et dans l'île de la Cité elle apparu
alors comme le symbole de la nation
réconciliée
[Musique]
le mariage de Louis XIV avec l'infante
marithérèse consacra la paix retrouvée
au Traité des Pyrénées tandis que le
peuple de Paris continuait de dérouler
ses longues processions à l'ombre des
tours déjà 5 fois centenaires
1789 Notre-Dame qui vit la bénédiction
des drapeaux de la garde nationale
faillit bien être démoli
sauvé mais détérioré il fallut 6
millions de francs d'alors pour la
rendre digne du sacre de Napoléon
[Applaudissements]
au milieu du 19e siècle le parvis était
encore étriqué par l'Hôtel-Dieu et le
bâtiment des enfants trouvés les
démolitions entreprises par le baron
Haussmann en quadrupler la surface et
les 40 mètres de la merveilleuse façade
y retrouvèrent la majesté que nous leur
connaissons violer le duc en fin lui
rendit sa flèche naguère détruite la
guerre de 1870 passa sans trop et
gratiné la cathédrale et en 1918 le TDM
de la victoire marqua la fin de la
première guerre mondiale
[Musique]
ainsi au cours des siècles le bourdon de
Notre-Dame n'aura pas cessé de rythmer
les heures graves ou joyeuses de
l'histoire de France
[Musique]